PAUL FREEDMAN: We are
starting to use primary
sources for our understanding
of the historical periods
under discussion.
Primary sources?
Writings by people who
lived at the time.
And as with all such sources,
the great advantage is
vividness, immediacy--
the people lived through it.
And the problem is distance
from us and strangeness.
Procopius and Gregory of Tours,
who we'll be starting
out with next week, are very
different writers.
Procopius much more conscious
of style, a layman was
somebody operating within
the classical tradition.
Gregory of Tours, certainly
a person for whom
style is not paramount.
Or at least, it's not the
classical notions of rhetoric,
smoothness, and vividness
that Procopius has.
He is a bishop.
He's very concerned
with supernatural
events and the Church.
Or let's say, supernatural
events
controlled by the Church.
Procopius, as you've seen, is
not very concerned with
Christianity, and the
supernatural events that
concerned him, such as Justinian
walking around the
palace with no head, are not
Christian supernatural.
They're from some other older
supernatural tradition.
But both Gregory of Tours and
Procopius require an effort to
figure out.
Why not just read something by
a writer, a historian living
now who may be easier
to figure out?
And who is writing with
you and me in mind?
Because of the vividness and
because of the trickiness of
trying to reconstruct not only
what happened, which is hard
enough, but also what the mood
of people was, and what the
reaction was.
We're talking about
Justinian today.
So an emperor whose rule
occupies most of the sixth
century, 527 to 565.
So we're concentrating on the
sixth century as part of this
overall survival and crisis of
the Eastern Roman Empire.
His reign, or more precisely,
the earlier part of his reign
until about 540, is the height,
apogee, maximum power
of this empire which succeeds in
shall we say, reconquering
or conquering.
Taking back or adding the parts
of the Western Roman
Empire, many parts of the
Western Roman Empire that had
been lost effectively to the
barbarian invasions of the
fifth century.
If you still can refer to your
map, or if your memory of
geography is--
OK.
The major areas of conquest of
Justinian beyond the borders
of the old eastern empire are
first North Africa-- this is
the coast of modern Libya,
Tunisia, Algeria, and even
Morocco, held by the Vandals and
seized by Justinian; parts
of Spain, coastal Spain,
Mediterranean Spain, held by
the Visigoths; and Italy,
held by the Ostrogoths.
This is the centerpiece
of Justinian's reign.
And for a time, it looked
as if he had, in effect,
recreated the empire of
Constantine and Diocletian.
But as we'll see, this is a
triumph with a terrible price.
The terrible price being that
it weakened Byzantium.
Now when we say of figures in
the past, or even figures in
the recent past, that their
policies were a mistake
because it turned out that
the future enemy would be
something other than what they
were fighting, we can say that
with the advantage of
being able to see
what was going happen.
In other words, there are people
who argue that the
invasion of Iraq was a folly
or that the expenditures on
the aggressive foreign policy
of the first years of the
twenty-first century was
foolish, because as it turns
out, economic problems,
domestic problems, the
mortgage bubble, was really the
problem that people should
have been addressing.
Or they should have been
addressing the deficit.
You can say that.
In its own way, it's a fact.
But it doesn't necessarily tell
you what people at the
time should have thought of.
Thus, we know from last lecture
that, first of all,
Justinian should have
concentrated on the Persians.
The Persians on his eastern
frontier who didn't interest
him, who he just wanted to sort
of pacify in order to go
west and make his conquests.
The Persians would turn
out to be the biggest
enemy of the Empire.
And so, you know if you were
plotting this out as a kind of
international political
strategy, you could say:
"Forget about the Ostrogoths.
Forget about the Vandals.
Build up that frontier.
Invade Persia, keep your army
there." And indeed, with a
little more hindsight, we can
say, "Oh my gosh, in eighty
years, the Muslims are going
to take the eastern part of
your empire."
Well, obviously, there's no way
he is going to be expected
reasonably to know that.
Except, if you're looking at
a distance, from over 1,000
years, 1,500 years.
Then we can say, sure, the
eastern frontier turns out to
be the point of vulnerability.
So a classic kind of historical
problem, or early
Middle Ages midterm question is:
"Justinian, overreacher or
reasonable guy?" Or "The
conquest of the west: folly or
grandeur?" And it's both.
It is a classic example of
over-extension, over-extension
of empires, meaning that empires
weaken themselves at
some point fatally by simply
getting either too big or
spending too much money.
And the two are linked.
If you get too big, you
have to spend more
money to defend yourself.
Not really having the resources
to keep what you
have.
The British Empire, to take a
reasonably clear and neutral
example, at some point is
simply too large for the
resources of a weakened
Great Britain.
And our colleague Paul Kennedy
has explored, quite memorably,
empires that simply could not
maintain their commitments.
The Spanish Empire, the British
Empire, and, as it
turned out after Kennedy
wrote his book, the
Russian Soviet Empire.
This is a pattern in history
that repeats itself.
The question, however, is, under
the circumstances, and
assuming the existence of that
empire, what are reasonable
policies to preserve
it or to extend it?
We know about Justinian's wars
of conquest and of defense--
he did have some wars against
the Persians--
his wars of conquest and defense
largely, although not
exclusively, through
Procopius.
He is our best source
in two works.
One, the Secret History, and
the other, much more
extensive, a series of books
called The Wars.
And they're divided in
Persian wars, African
wars, Italian wars.
In The Wars, you can see that
once the Italian war starts to
go badly, Procopius's opinion of
Justinian and of the great
general Belisarius tend to
change from a kind of
admiration and go, kill, get'em
spirit to uneasiness,
to blaming, to a kind
of finger pointing.
So we're dependent
on Procopius.
And when you first read The
Wars, it seems very, very
different from the
Secret History.
It seems like it's by Thucydides
or some other
sensible, objective
Greek writer.
And he indeed is writing
in that tradition.
Those of you who've read
Thucydides will remember he
describes, often, folly and
very terrible events, but
soberly, factually.
And in a fashion of Olympian
sorrow at the folly of
policymakers and generals.
And to some extent, Procopius
has that tone, which seems to
contrast very much with the
vehemence of the Secret
History, leading some people
to assume that he was crazy
when he wrote the
Secret History.
Or off balance, let's say.
Or that The Wars represented the
real Procopius, and this
represented his "evil twin." The
term, evil twin, doesn't
appear in Gibbon,
but it could.
It could.
What makes it more complicated
is a third work
of his called Buildings.
Buildings is, as the name
implies, a book about
Justinian's building campaign,
which includes, but is no
means limited to, the church
of Hagia Sofia in modern
Istanbul, which is, continues
to be, to this day, an
extraordinary building
of such immensity and
such space in interior.
A dome that seems unsupported by
anything and that seems to
cover half the earth when
you're inside it.
Both splendid and an
extraordinary engineering feat.
And then Justinian
built churches.
He built churches that stand in
Ravenna with unbelievably
beautiful mosaics,
Ravenna in Italy.
And these are important because
Ravenna was outside
the zone of territory controlled
by the iconoclasts.
And, therefore while the
iconoclasts tended to take
down or whitewash
representations of anything
divine, their reach did not
extend as far as Ravenna.
So in a way, the best examples
of Byzantine mosaic art of the
earliest period--
Not in a way, but absolutely
are outside of the eastern
Mediterranean, and in Italy.
Buildings though, is not just
an account of Justinian's
architectural essays, but a
panegyric, a praise of
Justinian.
Almost as slavishly adulatory
as the Secret History is a
condemnation.
And as I suggested last time,
these actually go together in
a society where a tremendous
power is concentrated in one
person, or one court, or one
setting, the reactions of
people tend to be adulation
which is, to some extent,
forced out of them, or at least
invited by the ruler.
So again, to take an obvious
analogy: Stalin, for his
seventieth birthday was pleased
that the greatest
museum of Moscow, all the
permanent exhibit was set
aside and warehoused, and the
whole museum was given over to
gifts to Stalin on his
seventieth birthday from a
grateful people.
He didn't have to order it.
Somebody came up with the idea
and he said, "Oh, don't go to
any trouble." They had the
thing, this adulatory.
This is what later would
be called the "cult of
personality." And it's just one
of hundreds of examples.
Naming cities after him, lauding
him as the "Great
Gardener", "the Friend of
Children," "the successor of
Lenin", and so forth.
The other side of that is a kind
of hatred and diatribe,
more or less secret.
There were lots of jokes
about Stalin.
You could and people were sent
to Siberia or executed for
telling these jokes.
But they were very good jokes,
under the circumstances.
This is some of the explanation
for how you can
get, at the same time, adulation
and demonization.
The interesting thing, of
course, is it's in the same
guy, Procopius.
And although people at one time
thought, "Oh well, he
wrote The Buildings earlier
and then became
disillusioned." He did
become disillusioned.
Everybody became disillusioned,
because after
540, things started
to go wrong.
There's a huge plague in 542
that kills off a third of the
population, for starters.
But it looks as if he's writing
this stuff more or
less at the same time.
The Secret History
is not finished.
That's why it begins so oddly,
not with Justinian, but with
Belisarius and Belisarius' wife,
being kicked around by
his wife, and Theodora and you
sort of don't know who these
people are.
And then suddenly we're
at Justinian.
Well, the order of this
thing is not yet set.
He probably did not finish it.
He did, however, want it to be
published after his death.
It's called the Secret History
or the Anecdota, sort of
stories, by later writers.
It survives in only
one manuscript,
as I think I remarked.
Nevertheless, because it has a
highly rhetorical style, it
clearly was to be read
by other people.
It's not just a set of
jottings for his own
satisfaction.
It is a work that he hoped would
be widely published when
he was safely dead.
And Anecdota literally means,
not "stories" as it would now,
anecdotes, the false cognate,
it means "not to be
published".
So in the Secret History,
Justinian is a monster.
Let's set that aside for a
moment and talk about what
Justinian actually did.
Justinian was the power behind
the throne of his uncle,
Justin the First. So
in a way, his rule
goes back to the 510s.
Justinian's character, as
portrayed by Procopius in both
The Wars and in the Secret
History, is very
smart, hard - working--
Procopius says he almost
never slept--
devoted to details, capable of
immersing himself in many
different things: architecture,
church
ceremonies, theology, and law.
He was of humble birth.
His uncle, and his family
were soldiers.
They were from modern oh,
Croatia, more or less, the
Balkan peninsula, the
former Yugoslavia--
Illyrians, as would have been
the term used at the time.
He grew up speaking some form of
Latin, and he is, as I said
last time, the last emperor
whose native language was
Latin as opposed to Greek.
He dressed very simply, and
he was approachable.
He did not have that
awe-inspiring splendor of
Diocletian or Constantine,
for example.
He was seldom angry, but he was
cold and seems to have had
no trace of mercy or kindness.
He reminds me of some
professors of mine.
He was intolerant; he was
unforgiving; and he was
merciless.
He had a grandiose conception
of the Empire.
And he was willing to tax his
subjects heavily and to
endanger the security of the
eastern frontier in order to
expand his territory
and his prestige.
I think that is a fair
judgment to make.
He believed that his
predecessors had, through
neglect, lost what the ancient
Romans had conquered.
And he believed that you
couldn't call it the Roman
Empire if all it consisted of
were possessions in the
eastern Mediterranean.
And, as we've said, he did
indeed conquer, at great cost,
North Africa, parts of
Spain and Italy.
He had a--
I think it's wrong to use the
term totalitarian, but
certainly a very strong
conception of imperial
rulership.
He tried to impose doctrines
on the Church in order to
resolve the age - old
Monophysite question.
He was no more successful than
Constantine or Theodosius by
the way, but, for example, just
to give you a sense of
his methods, he kidnapped the
Pope in Rome, tried to
browbeat him, and exiled
him to the Crimean
Peninsula where he died.
Theodora.
One of the most interesting
things about Justinian is that
he gave so much power and
respect to his consort,
Theodora, who was of even more
humble birth than he was.
Now, I don't think we have to
believe Procopius on the
details of Theodora's youth.
He certainly reserves
his most hysterical
diatribes for Theodora.
I think it's fair to say that
Procopius was not a great
admirer of competent women.
The historian Bury, J. B.
Bury, one of the great
historians of late Rome and
Byzantium, who wrote about
100, 120 years ago, describes
her youth as stormy.
An adjective that I like,
because it could be anything.
Her stormy youth.
Probably her father
was a bear keeper.
Somebody who kept bears for the
entertainment of people at
the circus.
An animal trainer.
She was the mother
of a legitimate
[correction: illegitimate]
child.
She may have had a background
of amateur or
quasi-professional, semi-pro
prostitution.
Notice that Procopius condemns
her, first for being a
prostitute, and then for
suppressing prostitution once
she became Empress.
There's a logic to that.
Procopius is not opposed
to prostitution.
One has the sense that he's, if
not a connoisseur, at least
a now-and-then partaker.
But for prostitutes to be
anything other than this
firmly subordinated class, that
is, for prostitutes to
have some sort of voice or
opinion, or for people to
endeavor to help them, or
respect them, is, in his mind,
ridiculous and scandalous.
Procopius is a conservative.
He doesn't like the weakening
of the senatorial classes.
He represents the land
- owning interests.
He doesn't like too much
imperial power.
He's quite happy to respect the
emperor, but is angry when
the emperor seems to be
taxing rich people.
He doesn't like upstarts.
Upstarts like Justinian.
Who is he?
A soldier's child.
Upstarts like Theodora.
Upstarts like Antonia, the
wife of Belisarius.
Justinian and Theodora
ruled as a team.
They had very different
personalities.
A very interesting team.
Theodora loved sleep, luxury,
was sympathetic to the
Monophysites.
Justinian was completely the
opposite: an insomniac,
somebody who dressed in
extremely ordinary clothing
and firmly anti-Monophysite.
They, in fact, supported
different
factions in the circus.
Here is a Giants-Jets
marriage.
The circus.
The circus was a arena attached
to the palace, where
the emperor would make his
appearances at sporting events.
Although we've said Justinian
was approachable, by that we
mean that people in the
government or in high
positions could see him without
too much ceremony.
That doesn't mean he's
approachable just to anybody.
In an absolutist state, there
are certain kinds of events at
which the ruler has to show
himself, or traditionally
shows himself.
So in the Soviet era,
the May Day parades.
There's a reviewing stand in
Moscow at the tomb of Lenin.
And foreign correspondents and
intelligence people would try
to see who was in and out of
power by who appeared with the
leader, who wasn't there, where
they were standing.
The Hippodrome, the horse
racing arena in
Constantinople, was
a bit like this.
The Emperor had his own box and
the people could make sort
of celebratory gestures to him,
praise him, and if they
were in a rebellious mood,
criticize him as well.
There were of circus factions,
as they're called.
That is, people who were
cheering for one side or
another, the most important of
which in Constantinople are
the Blues and the Greens.
The Greens tended to be somewhat
pro-Monophysite.
And Theodora was a partisan
of the Greens.
The Blues, anti-Monophysite,
Justinian was
a partisan of theirs.
In 532, the circus factions
revolted.
Partly, it's a tax revolt.
Partly it's factions fighting.
It doesn't do to try to probe
what these factions
represented too much.
After a while, they're
simply factions.
They're simply people
who like to fight.
Or who like to root for
one side or another.
But they are rowdy,
and even criminal.
They have very outlandish
costumes.
They expend all their money
and all their energy on
sporting events and
on rowdiness
associated with them.
This is not completely
unfamiliar.
The prefect of the city arrested
seven people for
rioting and condemned
them to death.
Two of them escaped when
the rope broke.
It always pays to
maintain your--
I mean, this is a tip
from a historian--
always pays to maintain your
coercive equipment.
Once these guys escaped,
then they were heroes.
And they were shielded
from the crowd.
They were put in a monastery
where they had sanctuary.
And conveniently enough,
one was a Blue
and one was a Green.
So the Blues and the
Greens united.
They ran through the
streets demanding
pardon for the escapees.
And when Justinian refused,
a riot took place.
The battle cry of these rioters
was "Victory." Right?
Nika, not to be confused with
sporting equipment.
Nika - victory.
The crowds tried to overthrow
Justinian and Theodora.
And in the process, they burned
down a lot of the city.
Justinian is reported
by Procopius as
being ready to flee.
But Theodora stiffened his
resolve, basically telling him
she preferred to die in the
shroud of the imperial robes,
rather than flee in disguise,
and mobilized the generals,
Belisarius and Narses.
We've met Belisarius already.
And they cracked down on
the mob and killed
maybe 40,000 of them.
How many people attend
a Yankee game?
About 80,000?
So 30,000, 40,000 people, and
that ended the riots.
Constantinople was
partially burned.
Justinian loved building.
This was a great opportunity.
He couldn't have asked for a
better moment, in a sense.
Of course, it required more
taxes, but people now had seen
the problems with
resisting taxes.
And so this is where we start
the building of the new Hagia
Sofia that we see today.
Built in five years.
Compare this to grand projects
like you know an exit on the
Connecticut Turnpike, which
take fifteen years or so.
The way you build something in
five years is by an incredible
number of workmen.
And lavish expenditure
of money.
The patriarch's throne in Hagia
Sofia was made of silver.
It weighed 40,000 pounds.
The columns are of porphyry,
many of them.
It uses a lot of glass in
order to emit light.
And the light comes from so far
away that it forms these
wonderful patterns, depending
on the time of day.
Justinian also rebuilt the
Senate, the baths, the
imperial palace, and in the
Church of Saint Irene, the
Church of the Apostles,
et cetera, et cetera.
He started his wars against
Persia before the Nika revolt.
And the war with Persia
is one episode of a
multi-century war.
In this case, it's over
influence in the Caucasus.
But it's really about trying
to protect Byzantium from
Persian invasion.
But as I said, Justinian's
interest was
not really in Persia.
He was interested in peace with
Persia and in securing
enough of the frontier so that
the Persians couldn't launch,
at least not easily,
a surprise attack.
And in 531, the Eastern Roman
Empire and Persia signed a
perpetual peace.
And Justinian then moved his
troops to the west, the site
of his real ambitions.
The Vandal War in North
Africa was a triumph.
What we're seeing is one of
those cases in which a policy
seems to succeed miraculously
easily.
The Vandals fell, it seemed,
without a fight.
Here, the people who had been
the terror of Rome 100 years
earlier, who had sacked Rome
in 455, who had seized the
granary of Rome in 430,
fell almost, it
seemed, without a fight.
True, the native Berber
population who were
subordinate to the Vandals,
desert people, revolted.
And they were able to raid the
coast and to undermine the
position of the Byzantine
occupiers.
The next stop was
Italy in 535.
533 - 534, the conquest
of Africa.
But Italy would take twenty
years, not one.
And in the process, Italy itself
would be devastated.
And with that devastation, a lot
of classical culture would
be lost. What wasn't destroyed
by the fifth century
invasions--
and remember we said the
Ostrogoths were pretty
reasonable occupiers--
would be destroyed by the
Romans themselves.
I will not tax you with the
ins and outs, and ups and
downs of this campaign.
Suffice it to say that the
general, Belisarius, at first
was able to triumph in Italy.
The Ostrogothic resistance,
however, proved to be much
stronger than he expected.
And Justinian recalled
Belisarius.
Almost all of Italy was
reoccupied by the Ostrogoths
and it was only the second
general, Narses, who from 552
to 555 is able to
take over Italy.
540 is the year that Ravenna
falls to the Byzantines, and
it seems to be the zenith
of Justinian's reign.
In that year, the Persians
invaded.
That perpetual peace had
lasted nine years.
And the Persian invasion
was quite successful.
It resulted in the sack of the
largest city of the Empire
after Constantinople and
Alexandria, the city of
Antioch in the Eastern
Mediterranean.
And this was followed
then by a plague.
The so-called Justinianic
Plague, which seems to be
related perhaps to the plague
of Peracles' Athens or the
Athens of the Peloponnesian War,
and maybe to the Black
Death of 1348, 1349.
Hard to say.
And in fact, research now being
done on the DNA in mass
graves from that plague will
perhaps tell us what the
disease really was.
Although so far, apparently,
it hasn't.
So from 540 to 565, the death of
Justinian, his policies are
officially successful.
555, the fall of Italy.
The plague eventually
goes away.
The Persians are pushed out of
Antioch, at least. But the
Empire in the later years
of Justinian is clearly
staggering under the weight of
taxation, economic downturn,
declining population,
and over-extension.
They had conquered Italy, but
the Italy they had conquered
was ruined.
And this empire, stretching now
from Sicily to the Persian
frontier is clearly too
big to hold onto.
So this is some of what
Procopius' anger is about.
But he's bitter and
disillusioned.
He says, "But I grow
dizzy when I
write of such suffering.
And pass on to future times
it's memories." Here, he's
speaking about the Persian
invasion of Antioch.
"For I cannot understand why it
is the will of God to exalt
the fortunes of a man, or place
him and cast them down
for no reason that
we can see."
Now if you contrast him with
what you've read in Augustine,
in The Confessions, you can see
that Augustine has some
reasons why this happens.
Procopius resists the Christian
explanation here.
And this is led some observers
to think, in general, that
he's not really somehow
a Christian.
He is, but he's writing in
a classical tradition.
And he is also, remember, an
"elitist" a conservative.
I use the term elitist in
a fairly neutral sense.
It's hard to expect someone
whose writings come down to us
all this length of time to be,
somehow, an ordinary person.
Yes, he represents a class.
But doesn't really like
religious controversy.
But doesn't really like all of
the fussing about the natures
or nature of Christ.
But there are other things that
are not in Procopius that
are somewhat surprising.
Justinian is best known for
architectural monuments like
Hagia Sofia; to historians, for
what we are essentially
talking about today, the Western
conquest; and for his
legal reforms, the Justinianic
Law Code, which is the basis
of all European law.
European, that is, as opposed
to Anglo-American.
Anglo-American law is a
separate tradition.
European law is based ultimately
on a reworking of
Roman law precedents.
And so I want to talk a little
bit about his legal
accomplishment, which Procopius,
a man who would be
familiar with law courts, with
legal systems, doesn't tell us
anything about in his works.
Virtually nothing.
Justinian essentially codified
the Roman law.
And this is important, not only
because it's the basis of
European law, but law is related
to political and
administrative order.
However much we may hate
bureaucracy, or denounce
administration, that is how
governments provide whatever
it is they are providing
for their citizens.
And since the alternative to
government is anarchy, and
since there are examples before
our eyes of anarchic
societies, it won't do to
underestimate the benefits of
law, however cynical we may be
about its implementation.
Roman law at the time of
Justinian was, as law tends to
be, learned and unwieldy.
If you wanted to know how to
resolve a question, you could
go through the thousands and
thousands of what are called
"responsae", or you could
look at legislation.
Just as in the Anglo-American
tradition, and some of you
will learn this very soon in
law school, you can either
look at statutes passed by
legislatures or court cases--
precedents.
The equivalent of a statute,
Connecticut passes a law
saying that you can't have
a gun in your car.
Whereas Texas has laws that say
you could have a gun in
your car under such and such
circumstances, OK?
So you have a whole set of
statute law, which would be
imperial statutes in the Roman
Empire, imperial legislation.
Or, if the statutes don't cover
a particular situation,
or you want something that
has the particularity--
a tree on my property falls
on my neighbor's--
did I mention this already?
Yeah, that one--
on my neighbor's garage.
Who's to blame?
OK, you go and you say, well,
this case came up in
Cincinnati in 1949, and this
is what the judge found.
In the absence of computers,
the search for this
stuff is very hard.
In Anglo-American law this is
called "precedent." In Roman
law, they're called "responsae."
And interestingly
enough, this term is also
singular, plural.
It applies to Jewish law.
A response is a response.
A judge, an expert, a law
professor, in effect, is asked
his opinion on something.
And his response becomes
preserved
as a kind of precedent.
These were voluminous and
represented centuries of law.
And even more, of course, the
responsae conflicted.
One judge says, "You have to pay
because it was your tree."
Another says, "It's an accident,
he's responsible for
his own remedies."
What do you do if you have
a conflict of judges?
What would you do if you
have two kinds of
contradictory responses?
You've got to decide who
is more authoritative?
Which one is better?
So the work of Justinian's
compilers was to sort out
legislation, statutes, and the
responses, and also to decide
among contradictory ones.
What is in this law?
Well, what's in any law?
We think of law as having mostly
to do with criminals
and stuff like that.
But criminal law is actually
very simple.
It's like the Burgundian code.
If you murder someone, this is
what's going to happen to you.
There may be different
kinds of killing.
If you murder them with intent
and premeditation, that's
worse than if you murder them in
a fight and spontaneously.
Manslaughter is different
from murder.
Manslaughter is where you didn't
intend to kill the
person, but you did.
You punched him, and you didn't
know they had a weak
heart and he died.
That's manslaughter.
You punched them.
You intended to hurt him, but
you didn't intend to kill him,
but he died.
Vehicular manslaughter.
What's the difference
between negligence--
you should have seen something
and you didn't-- versus
criminal intent?
You did it deliberately.
But it's very simple,
the criminal law.
There aren't a whole lot of gray
areas, and you can get
through the criminal code
pretty quickly.
But what about contracts?
What about property?
This is endless.
So you know in law school,
criminal law will be the
cream, or the tip of the
proverbial iceberg, or some
little side issue.
Most of your time is going
to be spent on--
those of you who go
for this option--
on property and contracts.
And that's what the Justinian
law is mostly: property and
contracts, legal arrangements
for buying and selling,
inheriting, partnerships,
guardianships, security,
surety, obligations.
This is a very advanced
science in Roman law.
As advanced as it is anywhere,
at any time.
This is very different from "You
cut off one finger; you
pay five solidi", which we were
looking at last week.
The work that ensued, the
so-called Justinianic code, or
the Corpus Iuris Civilis, the
body of civil law, was drawn
up in five years.
Here, again, is an example
of unbelievable rapidity,
compared with the length of time
it takes now, merely to
reform the Connecticut
tax code--
for that matter.
It was undertaken
by a commission.
Four books were issued.
The first is a collection
of statutes, and
it's called the Codex.
Collected laws of the
Senate and imperial
laws of previous centuries.
The largest book is the Digest,
or in Latin, Digesta.
The Digest is the weeded-out
responsae,
organized by subject.
So this would be where you would
go to try and figure out
what happens if a river changes
its course a little,
and your land seems to be now
taken over by your neighbor.
Is the river the border, or is
an artificial line the border?
The third book is a kind of
textbook, or a survey of the
whole law and what it's supposed
to mean called the
Institutes.
And the fourth is called the
Novella, or new laws, because
obviously, new laws would
have to be made.
The Codex, the Digest, the
Institutes are in Latin,
because Latin was the language
of the Roman Empire.
But the Novella are in Greek,
because Greek was the language
of the Empire now.
"Now" being 534 when this
work was finished.
The Justinianic Code is more,
however, than a rearrangement
of old laws.
It displayed a consistent
philosophy of government where
law is more than precedent, is
an active force in society.
The Emperor is seen as the
servant of the law, the
implementer of the law,
but he's also the
master of the law.
He is an absolute power.
He is the embodiment
of the law.
This is a well-run, immense,
burdensome empire.
Procopius gives us, unreliable
though he may be as to
Justinian being a demon, et
cetera, Procopius gives us a
vivid picture of a
highly-governed, even
efficiently-governed, but
oppressively-governed and very
ambitious society.
Now for next week, and a little
bit after, remember we
have no class on Wednesday.
We have class on Monday.
We are going to read from
Gregory of Tours about Clovis
and the Franks.
And it will seem more violent
and more primitive than what
we've been reading.
But violence and primitiveness,
unfortunately,
are part of history and
government at almost any time.
And so, enjoy the intrigue.
I'm not going to test
you on the names.
You'll see there are lots of
great cat names of the
Frankish barbarians.
But pay attention to the figure
of Clovis, and to the
attitude of Gregory.
Because, as with Procopius,
we've got an interesting, if
not completely reliable source.